hi everyone welcome to another oven
language design review meeting part of
our incremental language development
series and we seem to have a few topics
here today
extension to Nest tree and tree fold
I have a feeling there's just a lot more
to do with these but okay to allow Nest
tree to take a list or Association of
operators
gosh
right so in this first example you're
using regions to calculate the children
at the country level but you're using
subdivisions to calculate the children
at uh
division level
so you're saying
this is saying at different with
different part numbers use different
I mean we could imagine the same thing
for map
couldn't we
yes like a version of maple that takes a
list of
functions yep that says that different
levels do different things exactly it's
the same concept
um
and it's not a supplied type wrapper
I mean it's not a wrapper of some kind
where we're saying just like we were
talking about you know
things like you know
map immediate evaluate
blah blah blah
you know math
level I can already take a list of
exactly two operators and this would
this suggestion would allow
a list of any length
okay but I mean one could imagine
something like this
where you say
you know level selected
you know
one or two goes to f
three
or anything
or something goes to G
is that crazy
might not be useful I don't know
so you're saying that in this functions
in which we map something or we do
something at given levels and we have
two separate arguments this will be like
a combination of those two arguments
yes I mean but this is something where
you can select
I mean here
if I'm understanding correctly this
means zero means the root
is that right yes
so so I'm yeah I'm not entirely clear on
what problem we're trying to solve so
what does a list of two
things mean here
what does list of two mean right now
it's meaningless like you would just
apply the the list to to the function
okay
so so what is the what is the thing that
takes two you said something takes a
list exactly threefold it does have an
option for a list of two elements and
and that does that mean it repeats the
first one for all of the non-leaves and
it uses the second one for the leaves oh
boy
and so then what would an arbitrary
length thing mean use that level one
level two and so on
right well that that I mean that's the
complete disaster right because then you
you have a two level tree
well I guess maybe that would no no at
the end
I mean what you got to do is is okay
there's three fault yeah look there
but for what it's worth the thing with
Nest tree is is equivalent if you do
through compose the list
right but but my point is that right so
you you have some big tree with say four
levels and you give it a list of poor
things and it applies one to each level
and you give it a list of three things
and it applies things to the first three
levels and I presume ignores the fourth
level I'm not entirely no I think I
would have to do given the existing
syntaxes it has to pin one two three
four and then the last one has to be
rest so to speak
so the the last one is always applied to
the leaves
and and if the tree is deeper than the
like let's say you had this one two
three four but you had something of
depth five it would repeat the fourth
operator
which is consistent with what it's doing
now for the the case where you have a
link to because you give an operator for
the root and it repeats it for
everything except for the leaves I see
so if you had a list of lengths three it
would apply the first one to to the root
the second thing to all the intermediate
levels that are not the root and the
third thing to the leaves yes
okay so why do we want this in the first
place this thing about having
you know different levels because you're
saying we're using a tree to represent
something where the levels on the tree
and we're going to have the same issue
that we have at Parts where in the end
it's going to be like we really want
named parts that's why we have
associations we don't have trees with
symbolic levels do we
no I don't think so
it's more that you might have different
kinds of entities at different levels
and hence different Notions of children
currently Nest tree handles the case
well where
all of the nodes have the same type and
and the child operator is always the
same
right but the thing I can imagine is
that you want to label the levels in a
tree with you know country
adm1 administered division ADM 280m3 Etc
right do we don't have a good way to
reference
level three that is named County
so let's see what I'm saying
yes it's a separate thing but but yes
I'm assuming some sort of rectangularity
yeah
right
well I mean we don't have a named levels
mechanism for expressions for General
Expressions either
right yeah
I mean I would like to claim that that
would be a useful thing to think about
and something that may be relevant to
our new sort of data containers
if we had such a thing they could be
used in the association
as us left as keys of those of that
Association there
yeah exactly right so there's the
question of named levels
for Expressions
Etc
uh
I have no idea I mean you know let's say
we have
you know something like this
how would we even think about a named
level play for this I mean we would have
to have a rapper
around this that says you know named
levels
I mean I don't know this any of this
makes any sense
and then lots of things would have to
support that does that make any sense I
mean again maybe maybe it's coming with
data container something like this
right I think so
sorry I'll say what you said what did
you say I I I think this needs a more
powerful container like data container
not a dedicated object right because I
think you know that that then you're
hopelessly lost of like well what
happens if you have a thing
right that does like there's the main
level if that's embedded in something
bigger does the named level rapper
magically disappear and there's no way
to get that head out of the
all right what is the relationship
between data container and trees
well at the at the moment what's being
worked on with data container is is in a
rectangular things which is not trees
boy is this accent I definitely do not
know my British royal family
geniality lineage based on this okay
never mind
um I think it's a hierarchical
character that is common to both
it is that traces are more General
I'm sorry a common
yes okay it's only the hierarchical
character that is that is common between
trees and
and
deeper arrays
right but okay so the the thing unless
you hear is
does it make sense to have Nest tree
supporting Association syntax
with
numbered by level number right
yes or or the list I think actually the
list is like more fundamental
and then the association it was that
weird thing about the leaf
Leaf anchoring is for tree fold only not
necessary it's yes but I think the fact
that in trees it happens relatively
frequently that we want to Mark
different functions at different levels
I agree
and this is the this is the sort of
construction which would allow us to
prepare something clever to call entity
value efficiently
yes I agree
I mean I this seems reasonable
um
okay do other people have comments about
this
so do we agree with the report I'm not
entirely clear what this is
the proposal is that the first argument
of which functions three-fold Nest tree
which other ones just those two
what about tree map
well tree map takes level specs uh right
and
including sort of named level specs
right not not just
so I'm not quite sure how those things
would interact
right so this is the discussion we were
having before about merging the two
arguments the first and the third yeah
so it's less natural here
but the idea of mapping at different
levels like maple s is it's interesting
trima
okay tree map defaults to map all
basically
and
this is what levels you're mapping on
and the thing on on offer so to speak
would be a tree map of you know one
Arrow f 2 arrowg
on the tree
and then this level span
would be the third argument
perhaps it's a matter of having
respective lists so for example in this
in this example you were showing
when we have one and two we could have a
list of f and g
sure what's what's your point
uh I'm trying to to maintain the current
structure of three arguments
and instill generalize it
with one and two in the in the third
argument
I don't see anything wrong with that I
mean that's just a saying that
right I mean
I think actually the level spec is
independent of the function
like I think it makes sense to have
a list or an association with any level
spec I guess if if you use the
association you say levels one and two
but then the level spec is level three
you're just applying the identity
because you didn't specify an operator
for that level
right
well my my contention will be this looks
reasonable
anybody else want to comment on this but
by the this I mean the ability in these
um
function functions applied to trees
functions to segregate what function
gets applied based on what level it's on
objections
I'm only thinking of the case in which
mapping a list
might have had a many
is it possible that users might not be I
mean having an association does have a
meaning and that's more scary
that could cause trouble
right mapping an association actually
does seem like a real problem because
that's pretty pretty common thing to do
that's a problem guys
I mean it's a little ugly but it could
do a list of rules
I mean mapping a list I don't think is
worth worrying about
um yeah the only time I can think of
that is if you're preparing for some
crazy thing with through
but I think that's not very common yeah
hmm
it you know we could wrap an association
in another layer of list like have that
as a
as a workaround you actually want to map
the association
nobody's gonna know that they're just
going to get the wrong answer
how useful would it be to do the
non-association form
just the list
not support the association
so the list form you need to list the
operators at every level starting from
the root
how do you do it with the association do
you have a blank on the left hand side
list of rules instead of an association
well that's what Crystal was saying well
I mean like here so you say one goes to
f 2 goes to G but you didn't have to say
zero goes to anything
right and how do you do the zero in the
case of the list
in the case of a list you'd have to put
something there it'd have to be like the
equivalent of that the like identity
comma F comma G I understand that but
the first element is the zeroth element
really
it is the level zero
well with three
or with map that will depend on the
third argument right if the third
argument says from zero to something
yeah
well that's an interesting claim I mean
that that is Shifting where you are
referring to with the first element
right and and that might be why we need
a third element
sure for
for malice
and I had I had thought that there
wouldn't be a shift that the levels were
just referred in both cases to the
levels in the original
tree
I think with three is clearer because
you typically map on on everything but
if these was ever to make it into map
then we would have to be more careful
because map defaults to one
yes
okay hold on
that's a good point
you know
I really don't like the fact that the
association thing is not going to work
yeah identity with that no
so do we do a list of rules then
I think we should we should start with a
list I think that's the you know Nick is
commenting what about supplied
I'm not sure how that would help
well
so I mean there's
it's a little bit complicated right
because you would be putting like a list
in the second argument of supplied
it will be this basically
but wouldn't Supply be associated with
each function rather than with the list
of functions
right
oh yes the Cure function around the
whole thing in this case isn't there I
don't understand this pure function yeah
this pure function is
yeah this doesn't work oh I super don't
understand it actually yeah
no I mean the correct version of this
would be
that's very weird
yeah but I think this is doing something
very deeply no I agree the supply should
the supplied should be on the right hand
side of the of each rule it should be
one Arrow supplied around the f
right why no because this case is
totally different because this is a pure
function this isn't even the usage where
you pass an association in no I know I
know I know but this is an alternative
to possible Association this is
uh I don't think it is like what's the
hash level even doing like what I mean
that's saying that this has
tree map this this isn't an association
of operators this is just a pure
function that like returns an
association
right
oh I see this is structurally completely
different
yeah right because it didn't put the
expression in there
just try for your own sanity just write
a version below where it is what we're
talking about okay what is it
so you tree map and then write an
association
and then I guess one Arrow
you know F two Arrow G and maybe you
know Effigy could be pure functions and
you'd put supplied around the F and
around the G if you wanted to pass them
supplied arguments but why does that
help and what we're trying to do is
Select from the association using the
supplied level number
supplied what
okay look remember supplied entry map
right supplied
just to be clear here we can have F of
hash expression hash level
okay
what's that I think I finally see where
this is going
to have to say supplied here
yes
right okay so now what what I think Nick
was saying is
why not use
this
to do the selection
on level one
this will bind to that says one here on
level one yeah I see that it'll bind to
one and then on level two it'll bind to
two okay
and then these Expressions will bind to
because this tree map is going to visit
every node of the tree and every note of
the tree expression is going to bind to
the payload of the node and level is
going to bind to the level number
so I think it would work
I mean it's kind of stupid and efficient
because it's going to construct
everything on the left here
maybe you could use raw delayed
yes
yes perhaps
but
I mean I think this would work
this is basically using supplied to have
one function that behaves differently on
different levels rather than trying
specification for different yes
right although you couldn't right if you
wanted to distinguish between tree
leaves and not leaves you could do that
unless we manage to supply negative
levels or something yeah which we have
the the option to do in the supplied
specification
I mean you could also say this could be
leaf or not type thing as a value I
think we even had something like that in
the supplied mechanism
I admit this is rather complicated but
I'm trying to think I mean I I just
don't think it's going to work to have
an association there I like those lists
of operators because it extends what
we're already doing with tree fold with
the pair of operators
okay is it useful enough
another motivation is what Ian has in
the next section which is a
generalization that includes both
directions of going down and then going
up
and and it's a it's a promising idea
there is too much material here but
but I explained very quickly and then
Ian can continue so so the idea is to
manipulate a tree or an array going down
in analysis steps and then going up a
bit what data set does already in query
language
yes it's just that rather than having an
an unpredictable way of of knowing
whether an operator will be treated
going down or going up this has two
lists the list of going down operators
the list of going up operators so it's
much cleaner as you can have at the same
level something happening when going
down and when going up
when you go back up has it evaluated
yes yes
right so that's the big difference so in
terms of the the kind of the execution
graph
you see the recursion
going down it reaches the bottom
then it does the evaluation
and then
you see the next part of the execution
graph which could be of a completely
different expression coming back up
that basically the picture
yeah basically you get a result from
each branch that you took
and you apply results
I think this is evaluating at each step
so at each level that you cross it will
evaluate the function that you have
there so it can potentially modify what
you have and continue going down
same going up wait a minute
yeah these are all starting with the
seed value e to the e to the e to the E
and then using different operators to
build different trees one of one of
those should be you know have an echo in
it so we actually see
what's being seen at each step
what can you tell me what does this mean
this is this is going down and going
back up again is that right so this the
second argument can you highlight the
second argument
this um yeah expression transform
the if
so that is the going down operator
and then the third argument is a pair of
operators
I got that right so I'm not confused too
after the emperor scenes
and now
what's this
so here we have two ascending operators
oops
don't you won't you need an echo inside
of each operator or
this what Steven's doing is going to
just print the list of operators I don't
know if that's what it is yes
that's not what I want
foreign
that case I think you need the
the bracket inside the ampersand
that's what I thought I was confused by
being told otherwise yeah I thought you
were just trying to print the list of
operators I'm sorry
thank you
okay this
is a good case actually of where you
don't actually know where the bracket is
going to go actually we should we should
make sure this case gets fed to the
folks who are trying to do bracket
completion because this is
not an obvious case
okay let's take a little look here
okay so we drilled until we got to the
none
we logged and still we got until we got
to the nine
why is there an up to there and what
happened to that too
up to we put down an X because because
you hit the none so when you hit a when
you hit the leaf
can we see some other examples of this
can I see something where we have actual
non-trivial operations happening yeah
there's a neat example section and
there's a comparison with query section
foreign
so how does it choose between up two and
up one
up two because
it's the the descending operator
returned none so that's the last level
so it applies the ascending operator for
the last level
okay so this is so this is similar in
structure that the first thing is
everything except the last level and the
second is the last level
it's basically
Nest tree composed of tree fold
same arguments
so this type of idea is much used in
data set with group Y and so as you go
down you do group by
and then the data set is being modified
so adding more levels and then going to
go up due to aggregation type type of
operations like total Etc
so so this is an idea of allowing you
full flexibility of what to do going
down and what to do going up
is it obvious that you just go down and
then come back up again you don't bounce
around halfway and things
it could be generalized yes I I guess
this is just the Assumption of just
going one down one not
oh one of your functions could be
another expression transform right
yeah wow
okay so let's just bring a picture here
okay so map
goes down an expression tree spraying
things into it
then
okay then those things might evaluate
then one thing you could always do is
redo the map
you wait for everything to evaluate you
bubble up to the top again then you go
back down in again and
evaluate stuff and map again
this is an equivalent because why
the levels will be different
you'll have new expressions
yeah just think of group by again
a new level appears in the middle and
shifts all the levels below
okay but but
which means if you were to chain this as
a separate operator after the fact that
you would then need to know to apply
your operators at one deeper level
oh gosh okay let me try again huh
so
let's see the reason
I mean the F could evaluate to a 10
level object every F could make a 10
level object
right
and so
you're saying that knowing where to
apply G
how does it know that
how does it know does it apply G to
wherever
the I mean let's say that it made a 10
level object does it apply G 10 times as
many times or does it apply G only at
the places where it had made that
complete 10 level thing the second one
that you said
basically you're gonna have a call stack
like there's a function that called the
function that produced the the children
and once it gets its results you apply G
to that
okay to the results
yeah
okay and this is useful
right it's just it's essentially like a
map and reduce operation isn't it
as you come back up
it feels somehow ungeneral
for divide and conquer algorithms
okay well otherwise known as essentially
map produce
okay
so okay so how does the sapinski divide
and conquer
so you start out with the point the
three outer points and the descending
operator generates
a list of three sets of three points for
the three smaller triangles yep
so that's your map or your yeah okay
your next operation
and then on the way back up
okay so that at the end when it's gotten
to the bottom
it's made a bunch of points basically
mm-hmm
so for example if I said just to
understand what this does if I said map
all
I don't know why did that do that
oh because it's arguments are in a
different order
okay what is the structure okay I'm
sorry I'm playing with my own examples
here what are the arguments to what are
these functions supposed to return
what is this what is this what is this
which three
that the third argument does there's no
third argument to map all
right
now ball doesn't need a level spec it
has an implicit level spec
map all has an expression already this
is building an implicit expression that
never gets evaluated except for the
explicit ascending operators that you
give it
okay so if I replace this
with an F to prevent this from blowing
up
okay
so what will that be that will be
not quite resolved because it didn't
quite
but in the other case the reason it blew
up was because I had
I'm confused I had why wouldn't it be
why didn't I have at the end of that
other thing oh because I couldn't by the
time it was in the structure
of the list it was not going to evaluate
properly I'm going to get a little
confused
um
can you explain to me what was going on
before
I I'm not sure like so Circle points of
three is a matrix
yeah
I don't
know what exactly you're mapping on to
okay but I understand what this is
coming from threading
I'm not sure how this ends up getting so
deeply nested
because
I'm not sure I think it's level specs
are wrong
um
all right
look I think this idea though okay you
go down you spray functions onto on
things you come back up
awesome
I know but on
every place you come back up to
okay let me try and explain it this way
there's an anchor point
which is the sub-expression whose head
is
the thing you applied with map
as you come back up you get up through a
bunch of those anchor points
because the apps that you put there are
still there they may have innards that
you know you don't get back to the level
where the f is until you have recursed
back to that level yeah and And to
clarify one difference between
expression transform and query
well so query like compiles things to to
maps and things and basically sprinkles
operators expression transform is in the
nest in the fold family where the
operators immediately evaluate so it's
not like building an expression and then
evaluating it it applies and evaluates
yeah isn't that an implementation of Sue
not
not something else
I don't think so right I mean
whether
right it's a different writing new
structure or just mapping over structure
that you have
sorry to cut you off Utah yeah but right
uh
right well for one thing when you write
if you do things iteratively you have
some control over evaluation whereas if
you sort of replace everything and then
just let things evaluate they're at the
mercy of the evaluator
right those are going to get you to two
very different states
yes
um for example I use this internally in
expression tree to prevent evaluation
okay but basically
okay it was going to go down to a
certain specified level then it's going
to come back up again as it comes up
it is applying a different function
does it come back get comes back up the
normal map would apply identity as it
comes back up right
yes I'd say it's more the other way that
the the descending operator's identity
and on it and the operator that it's
mapping is on the way back up
but I guess I don't know the actual why
why is it that way I don't understand
that I mean
depth first traversals
okay let's look here I I think it
doesn't matter in this case given that
all the they are all going to be
inserted before evaluation in map
foreign
okay
so that's sprayed F's everywhere
so now let's imagine that our f
is actually something that doubles the
depth here so let's say that the f is
instead
U of V of hash
right and so the the the depth is coming
from the point when you let this
evaluate but say if you had hold of
like if the second argument of map all
was had had hold
that wouldn't happen whereas expression
transform can can eat things with that
hold just fine but the basic point is
that every U of V of something
is an anchored object we know where it
is you can pick up that sub-expression
yes but in expression transform
the new operators booked would act on
the results so they would act on the EU
heads the V hats rather than the
original
no I know but no but they're acting on
the whole U of V of d
they don't act individually the the
thing gulps
the ascending function gulps these whole
objects
doesn't it
I think it has to yes they're sending
yes yes I was thinking out there under
descending
the descending we just did here
so I think ascending takes whatever was
written by the descending thing
it takes whatever sub-expressions were
written by the descender
and applies the Ascender to them
after their inodes have been evaluated
right yes
to the
results of wrapping
the descending function
not just wrapping but evaluating the
descending function yeah right wrapping
well wrapping the descending function
and yes and evaluating it because but
the whole point is it hasn't you know
each one of these is a sub-expression
where it can pick it up it knows what
the sub expression is that's the
surprising thing because normally when
you do evaluation everything's going to
change but because this thing spawned an
evaluation basically it's it's applied
to the
the ascending function is applied
another way to put it is
um
is applied to the
results of evaluation
of the
uh
expression that the descending function
spawned
does that make sense
yes
and because it always knows what it
spawned it's never confused about where
it is when it spawned that thing
even though the structure can have
changed completely
the ascending function knows where it is
because the its corresponding descender
so so another way to put it is
okay
there are pairs
descend
ascend
that are applied
to particular sub-expressions
one on the way down one on the way up
right in other words you can pick the
sub-expressions like like for example in
this case here
we picked the sub-expressions boom
they've been it's been applied to those
now we can think of stage two
which is
for each of those F's
first replaced with the descender
okay so here's the way we could do this
if we said this
f of x blank
goes to I don't know what
X plus one
diminara
I certainly do
I see it doesn't sub do it okay but the
thing I was trying to do was I replaced
it with something
as long as it comes up from the bottom
and then whatever I replace it with I
then
oh boy this is confusing
so I I just pasted something into Zoom
chat which is helpful to me
uh
so right I basically took the example
um the first example only I replaced e
to the e to the E with hold of one plus
one to the one plus one
right so the first thing applied to the
whole expression
right then at the applied at the first
level which evaluated to one and
produced the log of four and then at the
next step it didn't see any of the ones
or twos that were originally there it
applied it to the result of the previous
step
so I found this is right helpful in
understanding how the evaluation is
happening
right
okay let's go through this again
as you're saying there is a one thing
that it does is spray stuff on the way
down
then it Aggregates on the way or it can
aggregate on the way up
I'm not really understanding more that
there is no down until you apply a
descending operator the descending Opera
operator defines the expression that
you're going to Traverse down it need
not be the one that you started with
as this example here shows
you know the expression you start with
could be the number one
and and the descending operator returns
a pair of numbers
oh boy
I think I more or less understand this I
don't think I quite have a clear way
right that's not what's not I guess it
decides to stop when
when there's an when it encounters a nun
it's not entirely clear to me right when
it returns an atomic expression or a
zero length expression yeah which is the
same way that Maple okay
I mean it could also be given a level
spec
but it will bounce from that level spec
it it does here it's saying Infinity you
could say three
instead of okay
so let's do a slightly more realistic
example okay
so I claim
and three really means three steps
because or three down steps right
because you yeah those those levels may
have nothing to do with the levels of
the input expression
um
okay where's the where's the data oops
the data stomat particularly comes first
okay so let's do
okay now my idea was
on the way down
I want to
add one and two
two X plus one
okay on the way up
I would suggest to add a head wrap the
two hash plus one in H or something like
that so do we see where it's placed
one second
oh boy okay who understands this
all right the down is showing me the
output right
yes yes
so down actually returns an array of the
same depth
as it's what it's given
okay
maybe we should be echoing the thing
that was given
actually we should probably Echo both
can we do Echo evaluation or will that
confuse things totally
I would just put Echo around the slot
Echo label
oh let's just do an echo because we
couldn't know where it's going to be
well those are going to be
actually the same thing yeah
okay so this is a Down
it got to the bottom
started recursing back up
no
where your cursor is or do you mean the
top you mean yeah you're saying this is
at the top yeah this is one thing right
and it evaluated right it did two of
that plus one as we can clearly see or
just
yeah okay
yep that was Zero
right and then so then it took that use
that
or I guess it went to where is that next
input
oh no but it goes one level deeper and
it finds the first Matrix the three five
seven nine
and then it applies there the down
operator
uh okay there's there's an extra set of
places that I didn't see okay yeah
okay
oh my God
in there so you see 23 when you apply
down to 23 it gave 47.
so that's how it knew to stop because 47
is
a raw expression
so that means 23 is the last result
yes
and now
comes back up in your up can you change
slot to slot two
which
Echo at slot
should be slot two yeah yes
what the hell is slot two
the first argument is the original
sub-expression the second is after it's
transformed by down I think right yes
the first argument is the payload
maybe we want to Lower Echo both of them
right so look at the 23 down gives 47 so
23 is a leaf
just let me just understand the whole
result for a second just understand what
the hell and does down have plus a pound
one then pound two or only up
only up
okay and only for the leaves the
non-leaves is just a single argument
okay so it doesn't do the most obvious
thing
well because it's supplying the operator
multiple times
as if as it goes down
right so
right so and then when you say original
does that mean like referring to Parts
in the original input expression or like
what's that
can you do comma H after infinity
what does that do
so H is applied to the same expression
that the down is applied to and it gives
a payload so the down and so the down is
applied to an expression and gives the
children
the H is applied to an expression and
gives its payload
and both of those things
so we're seeing those right uh right so
the so because you added the H right
that and we're we're seeing the H in the
up uh labels there because we're echoing
uh pound two rather than pound one
yes yes
right but I I still don't understand
what exactly
found where exactly pound two cups from
is it like
the last thing before this thing the
last down was apply to it well so you
apply it down and you get some
expression and then you place every
every sub-expression at level one of
that result with the result of
recursively doing expression transform
to it
that result expression is
is pound two
it's it's the result of down after you
have recursively applied expression
transformed to each of its subparts
instead of salt oh
this Christopher following this
foreign
yeah I yeah it's still not entirely
clear to me what found one on pound two
are
um
yeah so pound one is right and
like when I go to
uh
right so like if I'm at the next to last
line
uh
what actually Stephen can you uh change
that Echo at pound two to Echo at list
pound one pound two comma pound two just
so it's gonna give completely different
result it's not you don't want these oh
right
what do you want it to return we can we
can just Echo something and then return
something we use pound one as the label
for The Echoes like the two argument
form of echo oh yeah
so the thing you want to return and then
use pound one as the label it's the
second argument like that yeah
right seven so seven eleven
you see the H of 711
that corresponds to the 7-Eleven that
you see above
right
okay to which down had given 15 comma
23.
the result of recursively
transforming 15 and 23 is given by the
the list h of 15 comma h of 23. okay so
so let me rephrase this in my own words
so when we hit an atom or I guess a
length of list or an expression of
length zero we we just get the result
and and we're done is the app even
applied to it
uh because I don't see any 47s here
um
only if you do a list in the third
argument of expression transform
by default identity is applied to the
the atoms right and then although they
need not be Atomic Expressions they're
just the the last thing
right
and then
uh so for then
for each
I guess
output
we from down we we pair it up with the
input that produced it
and we wrap those in h and then we apply
our function yes
okay
and that's what's going to ultimately be
and the result of that function is going
to be what ultimately ends up in the
result
yes okay
I'm fairly confused
I mean the big picture
we still think it's mapreduce basically
it goes down it sprays functions in it
comes back up it is progressively
aggregating as it goes down
it's progressively applying functions to
smaller and smaller subparts
right I mean let me just understand
something here right and and I guess it
really is important to talk about these
uh steps rather than levels because
right there are no lists in that final
result because it
sort of I guess bubbled up and gathered
them together with h and our
total
um
oh there's a total there so total will
flatten it no matter what okay
so I don't
sorry yeah so I'm not sure if there will
be levels or not I guess I was confused
by the total
so I would say the one difference with
between this and both mapreduce and
query is that
in
like mapreduce and query the the
descending operators are are like
filtering and sorting
an expression that you have here the
descending operators
you know it's the difference between
structural recursion and generative
recursion if the descending operator can
return an expression with new
sub-expressions and you recurse through
that
foreign
does and query does not do
okay let me just understand map all
goes first down to the leaves and then
it comes back up again
right
uh
that's what we're seeing here
well I mean now what we're seeing is
Right map all sticks everything in at
all levels and then normal evaluation
occurs so since there's
nothing nothing with a held attribute in
here then leaves get evaluated prior to
the the uh Express right its heads then
leaves then the down values is the
standard order of evaluation
I see so you're claiming the echo
doesn't fire
because it doesn't have it didn't fire
on the way down inside map
because Matt was just constructing a
structural thing correct
and in particular if you you know put a
hold at at in front of say the three
four then you you won't get any prints
from any Echoes from
from there you'll see the literal Echo
inside of
oh my God what's that
well it went inside everywhere at every
node it inserted the function but once
you're inside the hold it's not allowed
to evaluate so you get every more
compound heads
oh gosh
okay
okay so the way I should think about it
even though I do think of Apple is going
up from the bottom that's only because
of the evaluation but thing but it is
going down from the top
but again the evaluation is structurally
recursing through an expression
right I mean so since since I happen to
know what the C code is like right it
basically goes down
each level and and and sticks things in
until there are no more levels to stick
things into uh but right that that
that's irrelevant the evaluate rate it
never allows the eval evaluator to fire
of course unless there is an association
in there as we discussed earlier today
yeah uh yeah
I know
once we have immediate evaluated then
it'll be more interesting to see what
examples like this do
I think the way to think of this is that
Maple is is insert all and then evaluate
all
while expression transform inserts and
evaluates at each level
and each level means the levels we have
right now which might be different from
the other ones because the previous
evaluation changes the levels what
previous evaluation so do you evaluate
do you insert an evaluator at the first
level that changes the whole expression
below
but the new expression has levels too so
now you go to the second level of the
new expression and insert and evaluate
really no how can how can that work I
mean so I I I I think it's it it's the
difference between structure like
structural and generating so
uh it's it's not that you start with an
expression and that you go through the
levels of that expression it's that you
start with a seed value and you're
creating an expression with levels
but that's just a seed value
you don't you care nothing about this
the structure of that expression the
structure that you care about is purely
the structure defined by whatever these
descending operators so so that is the
claim that
um the the
what this expression transform is doing
is that at Step n it applies the
function to
only to the by you know Expressions at
level n
of whatever the last generated thing was
no it's always at level one of the the
previous generated thing
okay
which is why I go back to saying it's
it's not useful to talk about levels
you're we should be talking about steps
right the the comparison with levels
only make sense with trees
because it's not the levels of the
expressions
let's understand what what we're trying
to do here you know for many years we've
had the ascending descending operator
Concept in data set I have never been
happy with the idea you know with its
generality or not
this is an attempt to
modularize and generalize that
functionality fast statement
yes I think so yeah here here you know
whether our given operator is ascending
or descending as opposed to reading the
novel at the top of the data set ref
page and trying to Define what will
happen
right
and and query can only do filtering and
sorting
operators not generating operators
what's an example of a generating
operator
do so do expression transform
you know
um
first argument one
second argument do list of two slot
comma two slot plus one
Ampersand this is so horrifying comedy
comma three come what comma G
comma three yep can't even imagine what
it's going to do
this is the whole point is it it's it's
generated a tree and and folded it
if you like the thing that you're just
you're traversing is the one
if we do tree of percent what we see a
nice sleep a nice view do tree instead
of G
literally do expression transform with
tree instead of G
this is basically how Nest tree is
implemented
uh okay yeah
this makes sense
this is the thing I'm claiming query
cannot do this is not sorting or
filtering the one it's generating new
sub terms
on the way down or on the way up
on the way down
the way down is defined by that that
pure function
okay
and on the way up
and we're opening these in tree
So eventually it wrapses in the rooting
tree and we get a tree out
yep
that's another minimal example let's go
ahead as this goes down it's finding
levels that were not there at the
beginning
because we didn't have three levels in
the one but as this goes down and
generates new levels things get applied
to the new level yeah
all right this is beginning to make a
bit more sense
goes down
it makes an expression
or changes the existing one
It's relatively in this case I mean it
just
every subpart is being
you know split here
[Music]
and that's why the ascending operator
takes two arguments the original
expression
that way that you have a payload and a
children
all right we're getting that but we ran
out of time so till we continued another
time and it you know the more clear
examples you can get
the better with some Echoes and some
trees and so on
yep um
but I think this is you know look I have
to say this is one of these
these things
I'm I'm remembering all the different
functional programming constructs that
we came up with I mean there was a time
when even fold was hard to understand
which it isn't anymore
and we'll get this one this one will
become easy
just isn't yet
at least for me
and then
you know we already know from data set
but this is a useful kind of operation
right so for another time
all right thanks a lot to people here
and people on live stream see you all
soon bye bye